[Musique]
paris 16 juillet 1942
des images presque oubliés de l'histoire
16 juillet 1972 trente ans après il ne
reste que cette plaque de la grande
rafle du vel d'hiv le célèbre vélodrome
d'hiver où se retrouvaient le pari
sportif a été détruit en 1959 comme pour
effacer un cauchemar le cauchemar de 30
mille juifs parquet dans le vel d'hiv
devenue en juillet 42 l'antichambre de
la mort mais il reste les survivants à
peine une cinquantaine perdu ici dans la
foule
les survivants de la plus grande
opération de police que paris ait connu
depuis l'arrestation des templiers et la
saint-barthélemy opérations confiées par
h manu obscur air de necker
c'est la première étape de la solution
finale celle de l'anéantissement des
juifs européens leur h 4 heures du matin
l'opération a été baptisée cyniquement
vent printanier au petit jour paris est
investi par la police parisienne la
police de vichy qui s'est chargée des
préparatifs et de l'exécution 9000
hommes
le gros des forces est concentré dans
ces trois arrondissements c'est là que
réside la majorité de la population
juive de paris je suis allée fait partie
le matin de bonne heure pour aller au
centre amelot où je travaillais dans un
dispensaire juifs qui savait d'ailleurs
de couverture à une action de résistance
dont beaucoup se souviennent encore
et ce qu'est bas surpris surpris et pas
tout à fait surpris en vérité c'était le
spectacle de ces
pauvres gens que l'on voyait sortir des
différentes maisons avec des valises des
ballons à la main et qu'on dirige vers
des autobus qui les emmenait nous ne
savions pas encore où mais nous avons
appris par la suite que c'était
notamment au vélodrome d'hiver où 7000
d'entre eux ont été rassemblés si je dis
je n'ai pas été entièrement surpris
c'est parce qu'il faut pas oublier que
nous vivions alors une période où les
rafles étaient quotidiennes mais le 7
juillet c'était différent
le cje bien été différent juste là nous
savions que des rafles avait lieu il y
en avait eu d'importantes les milliers
d'arrestations mais ça concernait
surtout des hommes et cette fois-ci il
semble bien que sont les vingt-huit
mille noms qui ont été fichés pour cette
grande rafle
il n'y avait pas de disque de
distinction du tour tout le monde devait
être raflés et emmené nous l'avons su
par la suite au vélodrome d'hiver où la
plupart d'entre eux avaient été parquées
y avait 4000 enfants pas mieux
sur les 4000 enfants parquet au vel
d'hiv quelques survivants lazare pitt
cowitz avait 14 ans en 1942 arrêté avec
ses parents il s'évade quelques heures
plus tard voilà comment cela s'est passé
les mères de famille qui n'avait plus
rien à donner à boire leurs enfants se
sont rassemblées devant cette porte qui
était la dentelle dire avec leurs
enfants donc l'épauler sur sur le bras
les enfants général pleurait parce qu'il
faisait une chaleur torride et il avait
soif il y avait plus d'eau dans le dans
le vélodrome d'hiver
et comme vous le voyez elle existe
encore cette épicerie était juste en
face voyez que la rue n'est pas n'est
pas grande
elles se sont rassemblées à certains
moments par la force disons quelle race
qu'elle représentait elles ont forcé le
petit cordon de police qui étaient là et
elles ont simplement été dans
dans cette épicerie j'ai donc profité de
ce moment où la police s'occupe
essentiellement de ramener ces femmes
vient y avait pas de policiers allemands
n'ont pas de policier allemand uwe
niveau que des policiers français
comment avez vous fait et donc à ce
moment là
du fait que tout disons les policiers
qui étaient dans ce rôle à ce moment là
se sont portés de l'autre côté de la rue
donc il n'y avait plus personne de 7
ports et j'en ai donc profité
je suis sorti normalement et j'ai vu
personne ne voyez pas s'ils étaient
occupés à ramener ces femmes nées ces
femmes mais bien quand il s'agit de
défendre son enfant il le policier ne
comptait pas beaucoup et effectivement
elles sont restées dans la boutique et
ils ont pu acheter le l'eau minérale qui
avait besoin elles sont leurs torts et
l'emmener ensuite elles sont retournées
mais moi quand même à ce moment là
j'avais déjà quitté la force
vous voyez cette petite rue qui est là
dont je ne connais même pas le nom exact
donc la première petite rue à gauche
jeunes des prises quatre enfants
s'évadent ainsi dans le même temps 57
bus déposent leurs cargaisons des
centaines de familles des pleurs des
cris l'image du vel d'hiv dira un
survivant est celle d'un bateau en
détresse
deux médecins juifs se souvienne je me
rappelle un cas de scarlatti les gens me
rappelle un cas de femmes enceintes sur
le point d'accoucher
je me rappelle les cris et les pleurs
des enfants
je vois arriver des gens de grand malade
d des contagieux gens qui avaient des
stigmates de la scarlatine par exemple
des gens des grands rhumatisante qu'on a
menées sur des brancards de véritables
grands malades et pour essayer de les
faire sortir
je me dirige vers le service médical de
la préfecture qui était composée d'un
médecin et de quelques infirmières de la
croix rouge j'expose la situation mais à
chaque fois c'est un refus absolu un
refus de traiter ces malades et un refus
de les évacuer
l'évacuation se fera six jours plus tard
pour drancy et au switch entre temps il
y a eu 107 suicide
trente ans après quelles leçons peut-on
tirer de ces événements
alors d'abord on n'a pas le droit
d'oublier
elles paient deux choses oubliées
pardonner
l'oubli nous n'avons pas le droit alors
quand au pardon il faut distinguer je ne
pardonne qu'à ceux qui me demandent
pardon d'abord n'est pas indépendamment
de cela le pardon est une bouffonnerie
absolument alors c'est pas maintenant
qu'on a envie de pardonner quand on voit
des hommes comme touvier gracié rentrer
en possession de leurs biens
se promener librement et et bénéficier
d'une grâce vraiment inexplicable
la première condition c'est d'abord que
les ennemis avec spi et qu'on nous
demande pardon et la deuxième est la
suivante le pardon ne peut venir que de
ceux qui ont souffert
donc la plaie est toujours ouverte
trente ans après la plaie est toujours
ouverte évidemment les trente ans ne
faut rien nada faire penser aux subi aux
six millions de juifs assassinés penser
aux fours crématoires
donc je pense que le problème est
toujours pendant est là bien sûr fait
toujours aussi mal
[Musique]